the biden administration is tightening
the economic screws on russian president
vladimir putin and his billionaire
allies known as oligarchs with a new
round of sanctions authorities in europe
have already seized at least two super
yachts and we do mean super owned by
those extremely wealthy russian
oligarchs and president biden is facing
pressure of his own to target russia's
oil industry ed o'keefe is at the white
house for us ed good morning good
morning tony incredible how just over a
week after this conflict began the
binding administration and european
countries are now going after some of
the world's richest people with close
ties to vladimir putin and now one
lawmaker saying it may be up to the
russian people themselves to take out
putin
is there brutus in russia is there more
successful colonel stoppenberg in the
russian military the only way this [ __ ]
ends my friend is for somebody in russia
to take this guy out south carolina
republican senator lindsey graham not
mincing words thursday night speaking
out about what he thinks it's going to
take to stop russian president vladimir
putin meantime some of russia's
wealthiest oligarchs and their families
are being cut off from the u.s banking
and their assets among those on the
target list vladimir putin's press
secretary dmitry peskov alicia uzmanov
one of russia's richest men who owns one
of the country's largest private jets
and sergey kemezov a friend of putin's
from their kgb days more than a dozen
other oligarchs and their families also
face visa restrictions
our interest is in maintaining the
strongest unified economic impact
campaign that
on food in all history the crisis in
ukraine is causing a spike in gas prices
around the world it's up an average of
22 cents across the nation since just
monday still the white house is under
increasing and notably bipartisan
pressure to ban imports of russian oil
i'm all for that ban it
ban
nancy pelosi is with us
which made me wonder what am i doing
she's right the white house says not so
fast noting just three percent of the
nation's oil imports come from russia we
don't have a strategic interest in
reducing the global supply of energy the
biden administration is also addressing
the growing refugee crisis announcing
some 75 000 ukrainians in the u.s as of
tuesday can now stay an additional 18
months
now this morning secretary of state
anthony blinken is in europe meeting
with nato allies to keep the diplomacy
going and later today finland's
president is coming here to the white
house to meet with president biden you
might think why is that important well
finland historically has stayed out of
nato and tried to remain neutral across
europe not to upset its next door
neighbor russia but a poll in finland
this week found now a majority of people
there believe the country should join
that military alliance just a sign gale
of how
alliances and politics across europe
have been transformed as this conflict
begins
yeah thank you ed for putting that in
perspective that's why it's important